Because I'm not a native Japanese speaker, because you're
drunk, because the other person is drunk, because I
didn't eat rice with side dishes, because I only
bowed once at the temple, because I
live in Bara state, until now.  That's because I was arguing with a stranger
on Twitter
about Gear Face. That's
why I say Naruto and Dragon Ball are
great.
Not to mention demons and giants, natives
don't spend their days killing ninjas from other villages. That's why
Naruto too.  Even though it was a good anime,
you could have bought a souvenir, but you didn't dare to buy it, so
yes, the police found me. I'm
not a native speaker, so you're watching me right now. And you're
reading these subtitles, so my favorite car is Hyun,
so that's no good. What do you think?  Unfortunately,
that doesn't make it into a Japanese teaching video,
so it's best not to rely on it at all. Still, the way you
hold your chopsticks is wrong,
so your thumb is like this, and more than half of the lyrics in that song are
unnatural.  Because Johnny's is made of English, it's
like there's no relationship between the consumption rate of Blue and Matcha Frappuccino and Japanese ability.His
girlfriend is Japanese.She
studied abroad at UC Berkeley, so that
Kumiko.  You can take the JLPT
exam next year. Once upon a time, some idiot
named this the Japanese word "Aru." I didn't ask him 3 times, so he
used "gael." That's
not a natural translation, but a literal translation. So you made a
video introducing the desk area.  Right
before you click So I watched the dubbed version of Cowboy Bebop, and I
know the dubbed version is great. That's
not the problem. I've never
studied the Emperor accent in Japanese.
[Applause]
I sneaked a drink before it sold out.  I see,
that sword on the drawer is made in China, and the
name of my conversation partner in class is Totto, so
I'm sorry.
Kumiko also said it,
but I'm too self-paced. Well, after all, I think being good at something is a compliment.